ich koche diese Woche für Anis Oma hallo
wir sind vom NDR und heute gibt es
senfeier und so habe ich sie gemacht
zuerst die Kartoffeln schälen waschen
und kochen Zwiebeln ganz klein und fein
hacken und diese dann mit einem
Esslöffel Margarine in der Pfanne dünn
und dann ein Esslöffel Mehl dazugeben
und schön andicken lassen Gemüsebrühe
und Milch dazugeben wir sind die
Zwiebeln so doll angebraten dass ich die
Soße durch ein Sieb gegeben habe damit
sie nicht so hässlich aussieht und damit
ist eine Senfsoße wird Senf dazugeben
und dann noch Salz und Pfeffer und
fertig mal gucken danke dir Vanessa das
ist ja lecker gibt's auch noch Salz also
ich werde verwöhnt hier bestimmt für die
Eier mal so ein bisschen so also
Kartoffeln liebe ich ja
wunderbar stimmt auf dem Punkt und die
Soße ja
und wenn du Punkte geben
müssen